this morning billionaire paul tudor
jones the ceo of tudor investment
corporation he was on cnbc's squawk box
and he was dropping bombs they just let
him sit there and go on and on about the
economy the fed and also bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies he had a very important
point about the bitcoin and crypto
industry he specifically said it's hard
to be a bear it's hard to bet against an
industry that has so much intellectual
capital flooding into it he specifically
talked about the young people inside of
his own investment firm his kids and
their friends how so many smart people
they're leaving college and they want to
go work in the crypto industry with that
much intellectual capital coming into
the market you just can't be a bear
here's exactly what paul tudor jones had
to say this morning
here's what i see i see
a generational divide and it's it's it's
a digital divide
and unfortunately joe you and i are
probably on the other side of it though
i think we're both scrambling as fast as
we can to understand it and and i see it
all the time in our quad groups i see it
all the time in my kids friends if you
look at the smartest and brightest minds
they're coming out of colleges today
um
so many of them are going into crypto so
many of them are going into the internet
3.0 it's hard
not to want to be long
crypto because of the intellectual
capital just
the sheer amount of intellectual capital
that's going into that space
and clearly if you think about the
ultimate dream of crypto it's it's a
borderless internet right where all of a
sudden you have blockchain
as the
verification code
to allow
anyone on the internet to instantly
connect because the blockchain
verifies who they are
and then that opens up just
huge possibilities clearly
central banks and central governments
are not going to necessarily be huge
fans of that particularly when it comes
to using cryptos and media exchange
that's the number one thing that's
holding it back
is the fact that you're
not going to get buy-ins from
governments because they lose their
ability to control
um
the creation and the in the supply of
money having said that
in a world where we're starting to
deglobalize and breaking down um
and actually probably going reverse
that ability to have the borderless
internet that ability to have to have a
store of value outside of necessarily
having your money to nominate whether
it's in
rubles or juan or dollars it becomes
very attractive so
i've got my modest allocation to crypto
i have a trading position
on top of that now i think that paul
tudor jones got a really important point
here when i first started investing i
had a very smart investor say to me pomp
there's only two rules that you need to
follow
follow the money and follow the talent
and boy was he right some of the best
investments i've ever made were me just
betting on people i didn't even
necessarily believe in their idea or i
didn't think the market would mature or
be as big as they told me all i knew was
that this was an individual that i
wanted to bet on when you look at the
bitcoin and crypto industry it's that
strategy on steroids if you want to bet
on some of the smartest people in the
world some of the best engineers some of
the best investors then betting on
crypto is a no-brainer not only is there
an incredible amount of financial
capital that's flowing into the industry
but the amount of intellectual capital
is overwhelming just as paul tudor jones
stated it's hard to be a bear on crypto
if there's this much intellectual
capital flowing in and i don't think
that any sophisticated intelligent
person can look at all the smart young
people who are working on this industry
or working on this technology can take a
look at it and say i'm out or i'm going
to bet against it
follow the talent follow the capital and
there's no place in the world that more
capital and talent is flowing than in
the bitcoin and crypto industry i'm a
long-term bull and i can't wait to see
what all the builders and investors end
up producing over the next 10 to 20
years